golpes gritos y empujones con imágenes
como éstas arrancó la inauguración de
las labores legislativas en honduras
diputados del mismo partido se fueron a
golpes cuando se anunciaron los
titulares de la junta directiva
provisional del parlamento 20 miembros
de libertad y refundación no libre el
partido de la presidenta electa xiomara
castró se opusieron a elegir a luis
redondo como presidente provisional de
la cámara optaron por jorge cálix
desencadenando una guerra interna se
consumó la traición xiomara castró había
acordado con el partido salvador de
honduras que redondo miembro de ese
movimiento político sería electo para
ese cargo pero los diputados disidentes
de libre violaron dicho pacto al votar
porque el ix ya estaba han decidido que
el asalto al poder legislativo lo iba a
hacer ayer estuvieron reunidos en santa
lucia
les pagaron a ustedes les pagaron
alimentación les pagaron de todo y ahí
estuvieron concentrado junto con los
nacionalistas dejando en abandono a sus
compañeros a sus amigos a su presidente
a su coordinador la pugna por la
dirección del parlamento revelaba las
primeras fisuras en la alianza que dio
la victoria a xiomara castró en finales
de noviembre el próximo jueves la que se
convertirá en la primera mujer en
dirigir el país centroamericano se
juramentarán marcando el regreso de la
izquierda al liderazgo del país tras más
de 12 años la nueva directiva del
parlamento tomará posición de manera
definitiva al 27 de enero el partido
libre espera que la elección de calix
pueda ser anulada